[Music]
on this Wednesday night more blockades
and more frustration rekey lots more
calls for the Prime Minister to take
action he is not providing leadership
and why one indigenous chief is
retracting his call for the blockades to
end inside the diamond Princess cruise
ship have a so scared why this doctor is
blasting bureaucrats major pile-up in
Quebec multiple injuries and multiple
vehicles written off and haunted by a
horrific fire in Halifax nothing can
prepare you for the impact of the
tragedy flashbacks to the fire that
killed seven children
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
the dispute over a natural gas pipeline
in northern BC continues to have
repercussions across the country Via
Rail is temporarily laying off 1,000
employees because the blockades on rail
lines have interrupted most of its
services the first time that's happened
in vias 42 year history the blockades
have now gone on for almost two weeks
today another one was set up on a rail
line near the historic Victoria Bridge
in Montreal and another went up on the
CN mainline in Edmonton do you know how
many trains go through Spruce Grove in a
day and that's the sad part some local
residents then moved in and began to
dismantle the blockade it and the others
are shows of solidarity for a group of
what so it in hereditary Chiefs who
opposed the coastal gasoline pipeline
being built through their territory the
natural gas pipeline was first proposed
in 2012 it's gone through all the
required approvals and consultations
with indigenous groups it has received
consent from some hereditary chiefs and
20 elected band councils along the route
but a handful of hereditary chiefs
oppose it and say they have jurisdiction
over the territory it has put Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau under intense
pressure this government is working
extremely hard to resolve this situation
we know that people are facing shortages
they're facing disruptions they're
facing layoffs that's unacceptable his
critics though say it's time to act and
end the blockades Alberta's justice
minister tweeted today Albertans will
not be economic hostages to law breaking
extremists there's words some of the
would so it and hereditary Chiefs have
left northern BC and are on their way to
southern Quebec to meet members of the
Mohawk community who have blocked a rail
line there we'll get to that in just a
moment but we begin with Michael Couture
on what political leaders are doing as
calls to end the blockades get louder
the sounds of traditional drums rang out
on the rails on the western edge of
Edmonton signaling more support of the
wet sword in hereditary Chiefs get
coastal gasoline to respect wet sweat
and law and remove themselves from their
territory along with the Royal colonial
Mounted Police later in the day a
manifestation of the frustration that
some are feeling some residents arrived
saying the Prime Minister isn't doing
anything so they were going to take
action and began dismantling the
blockade that frustration is being felt
and voiced in Ottawa where opposition
leaders continue to demand a solution to
the nearly 14-day standoff so once again
can you tell people who are just laid
off on what day they can get back to
work can you aim to do everything we can
to resolve this situation peacefully but
some Premier's are tired of waiting so
they held a conference call to discuss
next steps that they can take to end the
blockades we cannot exclude to use
police but it has to be done in
coordination in every provinces at the
same time that's not an option the
federal government is considering
calling instead for calm this is a
pivotal point in in our history
indigenous Services Minister Mark Miller
is in constant communication with the
protesters near Belleville Ontario in an
effort to maintain a level of trust and
he says the highest levels of
governments are working on a solution
Minister Blair Minister Garneau Minister
Bennett the Prime Minister himself and
myself as long as other ministers that
can include that can ensure the channels
of communication remain remain open and
are conducive to positive discussions
it's a whole-of-government approach from
a party that campaigned on
reconciliation with indigenous people
but Alberta premier Jason Kenney says
that ideal and the economy are being
hijacked in the process doubly
reconciliation doesn't mean allowing a
couple of people to shut down the
national economy late tonight the
premier sent out a joint statement
asking for a meeting with the prime
minister via teleconference to discuss
paths to a peaceful resolution
no word from Trudeau's office on whether
or not he'll take them up on that offer
Donna okay Mike look at or Thanks in a
sign of just how tense and complex the
issue is including among indigenous
leaders the grand chief of Quebec's
ghana Satake first nation today did a
u-turn he's retracted his plea to the
demonstrators to end the blockades as a
show of good faith here's a bit of what
grand chief Serge Otzi Simon said
yesterday bringing down the role of the
blockades doesn't mean that you
surrender like I said a wall of it
doesn't mean we're gonna just lay down
and let them kick us kick us around no
but it would show compassion along with
the strength that did not sit well with
some gana Satake Mohawks they've had
locked the doors of the Chiefs fan
council office and called on him to
resign today he retracted his comments
saying it's not his place to make such
judgments I've had concerns about the
potential consequences of such actions
but sometimes a leader you have to know
as a leader you have to know when to
lead and when to follow I am now
deciding to follow the people I
apologise for any harm or confusion or
Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes Stevenson
joins me now Mercedes there's a real
difference of views across the board on
what should happen next some hereditary
what so and chiefs are heading east from
northern BC are they intending to meet
with the prime minister or do we know
the purpose of their trip Donna we're
hearing that those hereditary Chiefs who
are all opposed to the coastal gas like
pipeline are flying east not to meet
with the prime minister or the
government in Ottawa but to thank the
mohawk who have erected rail barricades
in their support the goal behind the
trip is to strengthen the alliance
between First Nations and that will
begin as early as tomorrow when the
hereditary Chiefs will meet with the
mohawk of Tyendinaga in Ontario and then
on Saturday they had to go back to sit
down with the Mohawk first nation of
Ghana [ __ ] a it's all a show of unity an
expression of solidarity as they ignore
Ottawa's offer to meet with crown
indigenous relations minister Carolyn
Bennett the Chiefs say that they won't
talk to Ottawa until the RCMP get off
their land
but that could be difficult and
indigenous lawyer who we spoke to says
that the provincial and federal
governments cannot order the police to
do anything when it comes to operations
no matter which side of the debate
whether that's clearing protesters or
whether that's ceasing to enforce the
injunction in BC but Sarah main Ville
believes there may be a creative
solution if everyone comes to the table
the CN has has sort of allowed
operational police decisions to decide
when and when and where the bad
injunction was enforced if coastal gas
tanks was of the same mind sent we might
actually get a stand down by the RCMP
and Donna of course we bring you the
latest on how those meetings go all
right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thanks so much of what we consume and
what companies need to operate is
shipped by rail in this country and
these blockades which have no end in
sight right now are having an effect on
jobs and the economy
that's what Eric Sorensen is looking at
tonight the economic impact is spreading
Via Rail has announced 1,000 temporary
layoffs over rail blockades by
indigenous protesters CN says it is
laying off 450 workers in eastern Canada
after 400 trains were cancelled in the
last week and in Halifax the Atlantic
Container line is reroute mints to ports
and railroads in the u.s. several
business associations have written to
the prime minister stating they fully
share a commitment to reconciliation but
call for all parties including law
enforcement authorities to bring an end
to the ongoing disruptions
so is forcible removal and economic
solution I think that that's a question
that's best left up to government and
law enforcement small business leaders
want rail service resumed immediately
but there's recognition that forcing an
end to the blockades could be
short-sighted we want to ensure that the
resolution reached is something
sustainable the last thing anybody wants
is to see service resumed and then
suddenly abruptly stopped again the
blockades are just one body blow to the
Canadian economy coastal gas link the
frontier tech oil sands project and the
TMX pipeline all inject controversy and
uncertainty into the economy this
pipeline will never be built there's
political pushback and one environmental
spokesperson thinks civils the
obedience like the rail blockades could
occur over TMX as well we're getting a
taste of what things could look like if
there's an attempt to push this project
through BC right now and yet another
broadside to the economy coronavirus
china says it will have an impact on its
economy and Canada will feel the effects
on top of our homemade economic troubles
all of these effects are all pushing in
the same direction the Canadian economy
was already expected to deliver modest
growth and now things have are going to
be weakened by the the impact of the flu
epidemic and and rail disruptions Craig
Alexander says the rail blockades should
be dealt with because the longer they
last the greater the national impact
with coronavirus Canada will feel the
global economic effects together they
could turn current headwinds into an
economic windstorm Eric Sorensen Global
News Toronto now to Japan and what's
happening on the diamond Princess cruise
ship after 14 days of quarantine
authorities are now allowing hundreds of
passengers to leave some walking off the
ship and getting into taxis infectious
disease specialists say that violates
all infection control protocols at least
620 people from the ship of now tested
positive including 47 Canadians as Mike
Armstrong reports one infectious disease
expert says things were so bad he was
scared to be on board with more
passengers testing positive every day
there's been no question something went
wrong with the quarantine on the diamond
princess I can't believe it I can't bear
it well this is a video posted to
YouTube by a Japanese infectious
diseases expert Kintaro Iwata was on the
ship Tuesday and calls it chaotic Nevada
says over and over he saw things that
could spread the virus people wearing
protective gloves eating or using cell
phones papers carried from room to room
he says he's worked on cholera SARS and
Ebola and this experience is the first
time he's been frightened inside
Princess diamund I was so scared I was
so scared of getting copy 219 because
there was no way to tell where the virus
is we took he waters complaints to a
Montreal infectious diseases at
spirt dr. Cheng Liang calls it alarming
he says the theory has been that the
virus may have spread in the ventilation
system if it's because of the protocols
were not respected were not probably
implemented then there is no excuse for
that to happen with the 14-day
quarantine period wrapping up for
Nationals are now being moved off the
ship Australia and Hong Kong picked
people up today they'll be quarantined
in their home countries again but
Japanese citizens who haven't tested
positive are now free to leave dr. Liang
says that's a mistake considering there
are still new cases on the ship every
day they show doesn't be free they
should be monitored further a plane is
now in Japan to pick up Canadians from
the ship they'll be screened Thursday
and likely head home Friday for another
quarantine dr. Liang says this group is
more at risk than the group that was
brought back from China I strongly
believe that there would be a positive
cases from dinah croup you're not
beating around the bush you just said
strong I strongly I strongly I think
believed there were positive cases Mike
Armstrong Global News Montreal in China
where the outbreak began the number of
new confirmed cases is beginning to drop
and yesterday for the first time the
number of people in China who recovered
from the virus was greater than the
number of new cases more than 75
thousand cases have now been confirmed
worldwide and more than 2,100 people
have died the vast majority of those
cases are in China and Iran announced
today that two people in that country
have died according to Iranian state
media they were elderly and and been in
the hospital they are Iran's first
confirmed cases The Cove aide 19 crisis
is posing problems for drug makers
coming up the uncertainty ahead for
pharmacies and hospitals
in Quebec at least 69 people are injured
nine of them seriously after this multi
vehicle crash several emergency crews
are at the scene of the pileup which
shut down the highway around 20
kilometers south of Montreal at least
100 cars and 12 trucks are involved
authorities suspect the crash was caused
by a sudden whiteout as blowing snow
made for very dangerous driving
conditions another train carrying crude
oil has derailed the third in under
three months a cien freight train near
emo Ontario went off the tracks at
around 8:30 last night emergency crews
arrived on the scene this morning third
heat rail cars left the tracks several
are still leaking crude oil 13 days ago
more than a million litres of crude
spilled when a CP train derailed near
Guernsey Saskatchewan that was the
second crude oil tanker trained to
derail in that same area in two months
those three derailments have reignited
the debate about the safety of carrying
oil by rail across Canada more crude is
moving along Canadian railways than in
previous years as production increases
and new pipeline projects are stalled
the most recent data from the Canada
Energy Regulator shows the volume of oil
carried by trains in 2019 averaged more
than 250,000 barrels a day that's a
major increase from 2012 2019 when
trains moved an average of 143 thousand
barrels a day production of crude oil is
expected to increase by more than a
million barrels a day by 2035 there are
warnings tonight the outbreak of COBIT
19 could lead to a critical shortage of
pharmaceuticals and medical supplies the
majority of those products are made in
China where factories have ground to a
halt
and production has all but stopped
Jackson prosecco reports on the
uncertain impact on hospitals doctors
and patients
China's locked down cities and shuttered
factories threatened to pinch the supply
of critical medicines and medical
equipment around the world really the
supply chain issues will be dictated by
what happens with the outbreak the EU
Chamber of Commerce warns of a potential
global shortage of antibiotics drug
makers in North America are bracing for
production problems china produces 80%
of the world's supply of active
pharmaceutical ingredient those are the
parts of the pills that actually do
something the situation is described as
fluid in Canada experts have long warned
about the problem of drug shortages this
new coronavirus outbreak threatens to
make things worse there are a number of
marketing facilities in China that could
potentially be disrupted but we're not
hearing evidence at this point and we
don't want anyone to panic right now the
only confirmed supply issues are for
medical equipment like masks and
respirators demand has shot up 100 fold
and prices have soared right now we
expect that demand will outpace supply
for the near future in North America
experts have asked the general public
not to buy masks stressing they're
simply not needed and should be saved
for frontline responders all of it adds
up to a tenuous situation for doctors
and hospitals who may be forced to make
tough decisions if supplies are
jeopardized it's possible that in the
medium term while we start to build up
alternative sources of fly that
non-essential surgeries or services that
can healthcare services that can be
postponed ours postponed with so much of
the world's production centered in China
alternate sources may be hard to come by
both Canada and the United States
maintain strategic stockpiles of
medicine and other equipments they're
meant to mount a Rapid Response but not
a long-term one
Jackson cross Co Global News Washington
pulling strings in the ORR the patient
undergoing brain surgery and putting on
a concert that's coming up
Turkey's president has delivered what he
calls a final warning for russian-backed
forces to retreat from northern Syria
recipe of erawan says a Turkish military
operation to push back a Syrian
government offensive is imminent talks
with Russia yesterday failed to reach an
agreement to ease tensions over the last
rebel held stronghold in Syria turkey
wants Russia to force the Syrian
government to retreat to positions they
held before the advance into it'd Lib
and Aleppo for weak Syrian forces have
been conducting a crushing military
campaign and civilians including
children are caught in the middle he
fought the fire but couldn't save the
children next to Halifax fire fighter
breaks his silence this woman is doing
something remarkable she's playing the
violin while undergoing brain surgery
doctors at a London hospital wanted to
ensure her ability to play music was
preserved so before surgery they mapped
her brain and then had her play as they
removed a tumor close to parts of her
brain that controlled delicate movements
of her left hand the 53 year old woman
was diagnosed in 2013 she's been playing
the violin since she was 10 and the
surgeon who's an accomplished pianist
removed 90% of the tumor and left a
woman's hand fully functional well it's
been a year since a fire in Halifax
completely destroyed a home and the
dreams of a refugee couple from Syria
all seven of their children died in that
fire it's impossible to imagine how
anyone could cope the community rallied
around them and now for the first time a
firefighter who tried to save the
children is talking about what everyone
endured that night Ross Lord that's his
story
firefighter Brendan Maher admits his
burden is heavier one year to the day
after the most horrifying house fire
he's ever seen I think there's a sadness
that not just the first responders but
everyone in the community and I think a
lot of people across Canada are feeling
over over you know what was a real
tragedy the fire was very well advanced
and far ahead of us
before we got there we were able to
knock down most of the fire that was
around us but we weren't able to get to
the second floor to do search up where
the bedrooms were at first mara and his
colleagues were told there were two
people trapped inside in the end they
removed seven bodies all children
between the ages of 14 and 3 months old
a loss like that especially with
children and you know seven children
there's there's no preparation for that
they were the children of Syrian
refugees who came to Canada in 2017 to
find a safer home their father Ibrahim
bajo was badly burnt and almost killed
trying to fight the fire their mother
cow a bar host survived with no physical
injuries but devastated by an
unimaginable loss as friends and former
neighbors commemorate that loss there's
a glimmer of good news
doctors say Ibrahim Barr how slow
recovery is turning a corner every team
is recovering I think as well as anyone
would expect given the extent of his
injuries and we're at the point now
where we're sort of preparing to
transition back to the community in a
statement this week the bar hos
expressed deep gratitude for the love
and support they've received over the
past year they say they missed their
children every day mark commands his
managers for offering psychological
support that helps ease his mind
although flashbacks are always close by
don't walk out a couple of nights ago we
could you know it was clear night and
just looking up it was a bit of a it was
a trigger to you know memories of that
night as president of the Halifax
firefighters union he wants his members
to know it's okay to feel sorrow it's
just part of who we are now we keep
walking forward and you know share our
thoughts with each other embracing both
pride in what they tried to do in grief
over the outcome Ross Lord Global News
Halifax and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen
tonight's her Canada is lanark Islands
Ontario thanks for watching and I
to see you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]